[Musique]
près de deux millions 900 mille
personnes auront vu depuis 14 ans le
spectacle du puy du fou et la version 91
s'achève tout juste que l'heure est déjà
là aussi au bilan et aux perspectives
monique jocelyn la 14e année du puy du
fou vient de se terminer en beauté
il s'agit d'une année record avec 214
1105 visiteurs pour le grand parcours et
316 1600 spectateurs pour le spectacle
du soir
de quoi nourrir de grandes ambitions
pour l'année qui vient où sont prévus
d'importantes nouveautés à commencer par
la construction d'une galerie
souterraine de 100 mètres de long où
seront évoqués des scènes historiques
les plus marquantes des guerres de
vendée
le spectacle du soir verra sa mise en
scène modifier de façon importante avec
des effets techniques toujours nouveaux
dont un jeu de laser sur la fin du
spectacle qui viendra illuminer le
célèbre lac
ces renouvellements du spectacle sont
destinés tant aux spectateurs qu'aux
puyfolais dont il faut préserver
l'enthousiasmé la fraîcheur face à un
spectacle toujours en évolution
quand on sait que le puy du fou est le
lieu le plus visité de france
après versailles et chambord on comprend
qu'ils tiennent à garder son rang
[Musique]